du nom avec la tête mais il dit oui avec
le choeur l'hymne ont dit oui à ce qu'il
est mais il dit nos professeurs il ya
d'abord le questionne et tous les
problèmes sont posés
[Musique]
aimez-vous jacques prévert qui connaît
le pour faire le portrait d'un oiseau
lever la main oh là là il y en a pas mal
alors qui va nous le dire attends toi tu
veux on t'écoute offert la patrie la
moise aux jeunes à bord une cache avec
une porte ouverte
c'est parfois ça ce qu'on appelle la
poésie c'est par des gens qu'on connaît
pas n'importe où des gens qui donnent
dans la rue ou tueront les inventions
comme ça un tas d'enfants est agent
commun un acte héroïque du bloc dans la
rue sans le savoir et la poésie
[Musique]
je pense que le français de la fontaine
par une langue a vieilli certaines
phrases ne se comprennent plus les
élèves le biais 0 madame on ne compte
rien alors personnellement je préfère
prévert nous apprenons donc de poèmes de
prévert
je trouve que c'est plus facile et puis
c'est du français dès maintenant
là tellement rabâché à ton d'aller plus
haut c'est toujours pareil on pro-barça
changent tout le temps la prions puis il
ya les chansons il ya tout dedans
[Musique]
on
enfants sous la iiième j'habitais au
quatrième maison du 19e l'ont été sur le
palier parfois le gaz est coupé et
souvent les enquêteurs de la semeuse
cogner à la porte en tripotant leur
petit à payer plus
[Musique]